يعود اهالي حمص الى مدينتهم في صمت مطبق
وهم يحملون اغراضهم بحثا عن ما تبقى من
ركام
منازلهم لكن اغلبهم هنا يصر على التسليم
على هذه السيده التي وجدناها في بقايا
كنيسه بفرحه لا تعبر عنها سوى
الدموع تخليني اتذكر
كثير المهم اخر ثلاث اشهر صارلنا عم ناكل
نحن بكير
انها زينات الاخرس واحده من 30 شخصا كل
تفاصيل الحصار الذي عرفته المدينه لسنتين
يوما بيوم وساعه بساعه عاشتها تحت القصف
ومع القناصه والجوع قضت زينات السنتين
رفقه شقيقها ايمن داخل بقايا شقتهما
الصغيره التي كانت تشهد زيارات متكرره
للمسلحين المعارضين بحثا عن عن الغذاء
بدلا من مسانده هذا الطرف او ذاك ركز ايمن
وزينات كل طاقتهما للبقاء على قيد
الحياه يعني ممكن اوكي اوكي
اوكي من العش 15 يوم
بسور غدا عشا فطور غدا عشا بس ملعقه زيت
او ملعقتين زيت الزيت اللي حمانا وشويه
فلفل احمر بس زيت
زيتون
بالغدا شي شوي اترمه اعمله على النار مع
الزيت نفس العمليه يعني نفس المواد وفعلا
فان نوافذ منزلهما تضررت من القصف بما زاد
من المعاناه الى جانب الرعب والجوع لا سما
بعد ان فرض حصار على المسلحين في
المدينه مما ادى الى تفشي الجوع وهو ما
نحت بمسؤوليته الامم المتحده على كل
الاطراف
المتحاربه ومع نهايه المخزون اضطر ايمن
الى مغادره المنزل مرارا وتكرارا لجلب
الاعشاب واوراق
الشجر وحتى يحتفظ بلقمه للغد كان الاثنان
يصليان وهما المسيحيين ويحسب مقدار ما
ياكلان اليوم احتفاظا بامل للغد وهو الامل
الذي اضعفه نعم ولكنه ابقاه حيين على مدى
700 يوم من الرعب
والجوع